[Music]
okay so i took extensive notes on ways
to maximize our efficiency because we
can't be just as good as a man we have
to be better
yeah you're totally right let's rock
this april i love you
but i don't need your sarcasm right now
i'm serious let's get rolling i want to
get into some garbage
what i love garbage you ever found a
dead body in the trash
or body parts like a torso or a head
please say head
hey dewey leslie brought binders
what do they say pick up garbage put in
truck
actually yeah that's what's in the
binder on every page because i believe
in being thorough
all right okay let's do it trash people
whoa
let's feed the beast
according to leslie's binder she and
april are making even better time than
the guys do on a normal day
wow that's weird you know with us being
women and all you'd think our
boobs would get in the way is that
accurate mr fleckner is councilwoman up
ahead of the regular schedule
for this route whatever no comment
tough stuff are you posing i don't have
a photographer with me
google earth always taking pics let's
move it out
this is stacy knoblock's house i went to
high school with her and she was super
mean to me
and now i know that she dyes her hair
i knew that wench wasn't naturally
blonde
oh my god she has to use prescription
strength deodorant
this is the best day of my life hey
ladies someone just called in a pickup
we have to make an unscheduled stop
hope you can handle it it's not in the
binders a new challenge bring it on
stevie boy
april let's finish up we have some
stereotypes to overcome
and some privacy to violate yeah
wait no not only did we complete the
garbage route and move an unmovable
fridge
but the sanitation department hired
three new female
trash haulers and best of all april gave
me this present to commemorate our
feminist victory
and it's trash it's filled with trash
maybe there's something on the bottom
let me see no just
you